Bitte schön.
Danke schön.
Hallo Guten Tag, mein Name ist Kapagan. Ich bin hier zuständig als Steneristin tätig.
Mit Ihnen würde ich gerne das Akneume gesprechen.
Bevor wir über ihre Akteure bescheiden sprechen, möchte ich ein paar Argime fragen.
Sind Sie damit einherstanden?
Ja, ich bin einherstanden.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Willy Brandt.
Willy Brandt.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, B, R, A, N, D, T. Brandt.
Brandt. Okay. Herr Brandt.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
50 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Brandt?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,70 m weit.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Herr Doktor, das ist aktuell schwierig. Ich habe abgenommen und wieder zugenommen.
Ich glaube, als ich vor zwei Tagen gewohnt habe, war ich ungefähr 75 kg.
75 kg? Okay. Herr Brandt.
Okay. Was können Sie tun?
Herr Doktor, ich habe heute Blut gebrochen.
Blut gebrochen? Ja.
Deswegen habe ich, hatte der Hausarzt mich dann direkt ins Krankenhaus so hingeschickt.
Ja.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich jetzt hier bei Ihrem Krankenhaus in der Notaufnahme bin.
Okay, alles klar.
Wie viel Mal haben Sie gebrochen?
Zwei Mal war das gewesen.
Okay. Was enthalt Ihre Erbrochen, Essen oder Blut?
Am Anfang waren auch noch Essenzreste noch dabei,
mit so dunkem Blut oder das war so richtig bräunlich manchmal.
Jetzt beim zweiten Mal war dann richtig auch rotes Brot dabei.
Hatten Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Also, er Wochen habe ich nicht, habe jetzt so ein bisschen Brenn in der Speiseröhre gehabt, aber das liegt daran, dass mein Bauch so dick ist und ich kann nicht mehr gut essen.
Mein Bauch ist ganz dick geworden, letzten zwei Wochen.
Leiden Sie unter Schmerzen? Bauchschmerzen oder Speiseröhrischmerzen?
Kann ich so jetzt nicht sagen, nein, Schmerzen habe ich jetzt keine großen.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, seit zwei Wochen haben Sie dickbauch.
Richtig, ja, der Bauch ist richtig dick geworden so.
Für Sie sich wie Ballon oder?
Ja, ziemlich schwer, aber ich habe auch als nicht viel gegessen eigentlich und ich habe eigentlich jetzt auch in den letzten Monaten viel Gewicht verloren.
Und deshalb zwei Wochen habe ich jetzt wieder zugenommen.
Wie viele Kilo haben Sie zugenommen?
Also ich habe jetzt vor ungefähr einem halben Jahr habe ich ungefähr 80 Kilo gehabt.
Und dann war ich jetzt vor ein paar Wochen, habe ich sehr stark abgenommen, um mehr als 10 Kilo, da war ich unter 70 sogar.
Und jetzt in den letzten zwei Wochen habe ich wieder 5 Kilo zugenommen, obwohl ich nicht viel esse.
Ja, so erst haben Sie 10 Kilo zugenommen und dann abgenommen und dann in der letzter Zeit haben Sie 5 Kilo zugenommen.
Richtig, ja.
Also in den letzten Wochen, seitdem der Bauch so dick geworden ist, habe ich das gemerkt, dass ich zugenommen habe.
Also ich habe jetzt wieder 5 Kilo zugenommen, aber ich habe jetzt noch 5 Kilo zugenommen.
Welche Bauch haben Sie mit der Becher?
Also vom dicken Bauch kann ich mir jetzt, fällt mir nichts ein, vom Erbrechen eigentlich auch nicht.
Also ich habe nichts falsches gegessen, ich esse sowieso wenig, muss man sagen.
Also kann ich nicht sagen, dass ich das irgendwie provoziert haben könnte.
Sie sind Ihre Beschwerden plötzlich aufgetreten oder langsam zugenen.
Jetzt muss ich nochmal nachfragen, welche Beschwerden meinen Sie?
Das mit dem Erbrechen ist jetzt einmal.
Das war jetzt einmal spontan, einmal plötzlich.
Das auch andere Beschwerden?
Also ich fühle mich insgesamt ein bisschen schlapp.
Aber auch das Gefühl, dass ich nicht mehr so gut Luft bekomme, dass ich nicht mehr so tief einatmen kann.
Meine Beine sind auch ein bisschen dicker, aber nicht so viel, finde ich.
Also eine Unterschenkel habe ich so ein bisschen, eine Schwellung.
Ansonsten bin ich als körperlich schwach geworden in den letzten Monaten.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Es ist schlecht, es ist nicht gut, ich esse nicht gut.
Können Sie schlucken?
Wie gesagt, schlucken konnte ich, da habe ich keine Schwierigkeiten gehabt,
nur so ein bisschen Brennen hatte ich vielleicht ein bisschen,
aber sonst habe ich keine Beschwerden beim Schlucken.
Wie ist Ihr Stuhlgang?
Haben Sie Probleme, haben Sie Probleme durch Schwall oder Verstopfung?
Ich habe nicht so viel gegessen, deswegen war ich jetzt nicht mehr so oft auf Toilette,
vielleicht jeden dritten oder vierten Tag.
Aber ich habe auch wenig getrunken und wenig gegessen, vielleicht liegt es daran.
Früher hätten Sie nicht ähnliche Beschwerden,
und zwei Wochen haben Sie dicken Bauch.
Heute Morgen haben Sie erbrochen, zwei Mal.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe keine Fieber, nein.
Leiden Sie unter Schütterprost oder nach Schweiß?
Nein.
Sie haben Atemnot, Ihre Atemnot ist,
treten Ihre Atemnot bei Belastung oder in Ruhe?
Also ich würde sagen, weder noch, also ich belaste mich nicht,
ich habe auch keine Atemnot in dem Sinn,
ich kann nur nicht mehr so tief einatmen,
da habe ich das Gefühl, dass es ein bisschen schockt,
aber ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich jetzt ganz starke Atemnot habe,
das ist nicht der Fall.
Versten Sie?
Nein.
Leiden Sie unter Klopfen oder Herstrasen?
Haben Sie gemerkt?
Ist mir nichts aufgefallen, nein.
Trinken Sie nicht genug Wasser?
Ich trinke nicht genug Wasser, ja.
Ein, ein, ein etablierter höchstens pro Tag.
Ist Ihnen nun übel,
für den Erbrochen?
Also bevor ich das Erbrechen hatte, war mir ein bisschen übel,
jetzt ist jetzt nicht mehr.
Ist Ihnen momentan schwindelig oder früher so ein bisschen, ja.
Können Sie gut ein- und durch- schlafen,
in letzter Zeit?
Da habe ich jetzt keine Probleme.
Haben Sie bewusstlos sein?
Ob ich bewusstlos war? Nein, ich war nicht bewusstlos.
Herr Brandt, haben Sie an bestimmte Krönchen erkrankt?
Ich habe mal Licht gehabt, aber es ist auch schon länger her.
Dann habe ich diese COPD-Krankheit vom Rauchen, hat mir der Arzt gesagt.
Dann hatte ich mal eine Operation von einer Beinartier, die war zu.
Das musste dann aufgedehnt werden, da ist dann ein Stent gesetzt worden.
War Ihre Beingefeste verstuppt?
Das war wohl so, die haben es untersucht und dann haben sie gesagt, da muss man ein Stent machen.
Ich hatte mal eine Operation nach dem Sturz, da habe ich mir in Linke die Hüfte gebrochen.
Das war vor 6-7 Jahren ungefähr.
Brauchen Sie Medikamente wegen COPD?
Ja, da habe ich so ein Spray.
Wissen Sie Ihre Medikamente?
Atrovent.
Wenigstens Sie Baybedarf?
Nein, regelmäßig, dann mache ich 3 mal 2 Hübe pro Tag.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ich wurde an der Hand operiert, da war meine Finger so verkrampft, dann habe ich hier so eine Operation gemacht, die Finger wegen der Aufgehung.
Herr Brandt, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche.
Wie viel Schatten rauchen Sie pro Tag?
1 bis 1,5.
20 oder 30 Zigaretten?
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja.
Wie viel Glas oder wie viel Liter Bier?
Bier, ich bin ehrlich, das sind so 6-7 Flaschen pro Tag, die ich immer trinke, halber Kasten pro Tag geht drauf.
Herr Brandt, das ist nicht persönlich fragend, sondern routine medizinische Fragen.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, ich habe keine Drogen genommen.
Haben Sie früher probiert?
Hoffentlich nein.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Nein.
Herr Brandt, haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit gegen etwas?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Haben Sie alle Grundimpfungen erhalten?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Das ist schon lange her, dass ich geimpft worden bin, also kann mich nicht erinnern.
Sind Sie vollständig gegen Corona?
Gegen Corona habe ich 3 Impfungen gehabt.
Reisen Sie nach Ostland im letzter Zeit?
Nein.
Haben Sie lange Reise gemacht?
Nein, ich war schon lange nicht mehr im Urlaub.
Herr Brandt, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Die sind gestorben.
Woran sind Sie gestorben?
Mein Vater hatte Lungkrebs und meine Mutter hatte Schlaganfall.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe noch 2 Geschwister, aber ich habe keinen Kontakt zu denen.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Leben Sie allein?
Ich lebe alleine.
Was verheiratet Sie von Beruf?
Also, ich bin seit 10 Jahren arbeitslos.
Vorher habe ich auf dem Bau gearbeitet.
Ich habe auch Maura gelernt.
Bleiben Sie unter Momentan Übelkeit?
Nein, vor dem Erbrechen hatte ich Übelkahl, aber jetzt nicht.
Herr Brandt, Sie haben seit 2 Wochen einen dicken Bauch.
Heute haben Sie 2 Mal dunkelbraun gebrochen.
Sie haben auch Blut.
Sie haben seit 5 kg zugenommen, aber früher hatten sie 10 kg verloren.
Vorher habe ich verzinkt.
Sie leiden momentan unter Schenkel ödeme.
Was ist das?
Die Dickebeine haben Sie.
Sie brauchen tief zu atmen.
Sie fühlen sich müde.
Leiden Sie unter Sortbrennen?
Ja, seit dem Bausputik ist, habe ich das Gefühl, es brennt immer.
Seit wann fühlen Sie sich das?
Ich habe die wichtigsten Sachen gefragt.
Was meinen Sie, muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Sie sollen im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Ich untersuche sie körperlich.
Ich werde sie von Ihnen abnehmen.
Sie haben die Ultraschall-Beibedarf-City, die Gegebenen-Facity-Bau-Tomografie veranlasst.
Mit der Symptome und der Untersuchungsschrift besprechen wir mit meinem Chefarzt.
Wenn die Blutung noch mal auftritt, was meinen Sie?
Ich lege zuerst einen Zugang ein.
Nach der Untersuchung werde ich diese Prozesse zulegen.
Ich verstehe Ihre Angst.
Ich werde alles mit Ihnen zu helfen.
Danke schön.
Ich habe noch eine Liste von meinen Medikamenten.
Wollen Sie aufschreiben?
Ich werde Sie untersuchen.
Dann sind wir fertig.
Ich werde Sie über die Frage und die Kommentare beantworten.
Wie damals?
Sie waren heute?
Ja.
Sie haben mich geschickt mit Blutung.
Wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Seit wann?
Seit 20 Jahren.
Wie ist die Hautfarbe?
Die Augen und die Hautfarbe waren normal.
Ich habe es vor 3-4 Tagen stuhlgegangen.
Müssen Sie aufstoßen?
Wenig.
Seit wann haben Sie unter COPD?
10 Jahre.
Was ist mit Mund?
Sie haben Blut im Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Bein-Ödem hat er ein bisschen Unterschünkel-Ödem.
Sie kommen wegen Blutung.
Ich würde gerne Blutdruck, Puls und Sauerstoffsättigung messen.
Damit die Blutdruck-Ödem nicht mehr verblüht.
Ich würde gerne Blutdruck, Puls und Sauerstoff-Sättigung messen.
Damit wir weiter machen können.
Wie schockt sich das?
Gehen Sie auf die Toilette als gewöhnlich?
Wie gewöhnlich?
Ja, mehr als gewöhnlich.
Wie ist das bei der Stuhlgang?
Wie soll man das fragen?
Wenn Sie sich verletzen und Blutdruck...
Das dauert länger, als normal, dass die Blutung steht.
Wenn Sie sich verletzen und sich verletzen...
Entschuldigt Sie warum die daylight'.
1,5 Schatten betrachten pro Tag ungefähr.
Jukreis hat gesagt, nein, kein Geldpferdpunkt der Haut kann Jukreis noch nicht,
vielleicht kann man sagen.
Wie viel haben Sie erbrochen oder wie viele haben Sie erbrochen?
Eine Handvoll oder eine Eimervoll hat gesagt ungefähr eine halbe Eimervoll.
Notaball Eimernen bügt man auch, normal Eimerleichter, 5 Liter oder so.
Baja, yok kann man wieder.
Olur, başka Sorosu oder Katkesolmen,
oder auch ein paar Soros.
Olur mu?
Hallo Herr Oberarzt, haben Sie kurze Zeit?
Ja, ich habe einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen,
Herr Willi Brandt, 50 Jahre alt und 1 Meter, 70 kg groß und 75 kg schwer.
Herr Brandt hat sich in unserem Krankenhaus,
seit heute wegen zweimal erbrochen und
erbrochen vorgestellt.
Wie kann man das anders sagen?
Vollgefühlt.
Vollgefühlt, ja, aber wenn der Bauch dick wird, wie kann man das noch sagen?
Vollbauch, das akute.
Akut ist ja nicht, nein.
Man kann sagen Bauch, Umfangsvermehrung.
Ja, mehr Theorismus kann sein, muss aber nicht.
Es kann auch andere Gründe haben.
Sein Bauchumfang hat zugenommen.
Vermehrung des Bauchumfangs.
Seit zwei Wochen Bauchumfangszunahme.
Ja, außer dann klicken wir da präzisient über Bauchumfälle.
Bauchumfangsvermehrung, können Sie aufschreiben?
Umfangsvermehrung.
Ja, der Patient berichtet, dass die Beschwerden plötzlich aufgetreten seien.
Und er würde um seine Hausarzt zu uns überwiesen.
Seit einer Woche leider sordbrennen.
Unter sordbrennen.
Er trinke nicht genug Wasser und esse eher nicht genug.
Er hat 5 kg Wasser genommen.
Und vorher hat er 10 kg gewischt verloren.
Ja.
Die vegetative Anamnese,
die Gewichtszunahme sind unauffällig.
Er habe auch Obstpation.
Jede vier Tage muss er Stullgang gehen.
Er leidet an COPD seit 10 Jahren.
Er nimmt mit COPD 2 Mal ein.
Er will den Emblemis seit 14 Jahren erfolgen.
Er hat 5 Handfinger erfolgt.
Er hat 7 Jahre erfolgt.
Er hat eine Nikotin-Abusis von 30 Zigaretten pro Tag seit 30 Jahren.
Er hat 6 Bias pro Tag.
Er ist am Abortlex gestorben.
Er lebt allein und er habe keine Kinder.
Er ist seit 10 Jahren arbeitslos.
Er lebt am ersten Tag.
Er lebt am nächsten Tag.
Er lebt 5 Kilometer seit 5 Jahren.
Warum hat er das zugenommen?
Er hat 5 Kilometer im Bauch.
Er hat 5 Liter Wasser im Bauch.
Er lebt am nächsten Tag.